today we're featuring Craig Venter a
world-renowned biotechnologist known for
his groundbreaking contributions to
genomics he had a pivotal role in
leading the first draft sequence of the
human genome and assembling the
pioneering team that achieved the
transection of a cell with a synthetic
chromosome the cells are very Dynamic
changing second to second but one thing
is fundamental to all life and that's
the genetic code later in life he and
his research team created the world's
first synthetic organism from scratch
demonstrating the potential of synthetic
biology to engineer life at the
molecular level taking those Gene
Pathways putting them in synthetic
organisms will be able to create whole
new chemical libraries Craig's a leading
figure he's hilarious unfettered
Unshackled and unafraid you'll hear all
of that in this episode and find out why
he was among Time magazine's 100 most
influential people in the world not once
but twice maybe on another another
planet where life already exists so
without further Ado we welcome a lively
episode of the into the impossible
podcast my friend Craig Venter Live
recorded at UCSD this past fall welcome
back to our extended session with none
other than Dr Craig Venter who is
incredible intellect and influence on so
many of us and I wanted to solicit
questions and so I did take them on
Twitter X and also on Instagram and on
my YouTube channel Dr Brian keing is the
handle for all those so we're going to
get some some wild and interesting stuff
ranging from panspermia to uaps to life
at other planets but we're going to
begin with a more you know close to home
Okay so the first question hi Brian it
may be and this is from Dr Thomas derage
it may be interesting to talk about
cancer and the somatic mutation Theory
any ideas as where there has been so
little to no advance in survival for
most advanced solid tumors despite our
understanding of the human genome do you
believe Craig that cancer is purely a
genetic disease
well it's definitely a genetic disease
but that doesn't mean its ultimate cause
is genetics radiation causes cancer by
mutating The genome so it's the
radiation that causes the cancer same
things happen with chemical exposure UV
light um I've on my uh I think 12th or
14th round of Mo surgery the surgeon
said you know have you been exposed to
sunlight I said for 77 years you know
and and you know I was exposed to
sunlight long before there was
sunscreen uh so I I have more than my
share of skin cancer from UV light
exposure my father-in-law had acne
treated using uh x-rays back in the 60s
yeah and x-rays are definitely a a
carcinogen on their own so but these
things change the genetic code so human
longevity we would sequence the
individual's genome and sequence the
tumor's genome and you find all the
genes that are mutated and it turns out
these can be very useful and a lot of
therapies are being developed on the
term we use is
neoantigens because it's a mutated
protein it actually changes the
structure of the protein and the immune
system can recognize it and there's been
attempts to take these out and see which
tea cells recognize them uh and then
make more of that peptide to give it as
a vaccine against the individual tumor
so it's it's a personalized vaccine
approach uh and it uh has seen some
success I think Steve Rosenberg was the
first to do it with melanoma it hasn't
been
Universal you we haven't worked out all
the rules on it yet but yes cancer is a
uh it's based on changes in genetics
another question regarding genetics and
modification comes from user X N4 W I'm
not going to read it although that was
my choice for my uh second child's name
uh ex user ex okay uh he or she's asking
do GMOs genetically modified organisms
affect our DNA if so to what extent only
through the plasticity of your brain be
infected by that notion that they do
anything negative okay this is a a
possibly contentious one this comes from
a man whose name is an atony Gene like
uh your friend who came with the
algorithm that you mentioned a suitable
name for his job or her job he or she is
asking why weren't you able to create
life what's the missing spark the reason
this is a good question is that I don't
know if he'd argue that he did or didn't
so did you create life if so what was
the missing spark or if you did not what
what is the necessary
laun that is missing so right now all
life that we know comes from
pre-existing
life and even the synthetic cell we made
we made a totally new species that never
existed before but we use an existing
cell to transplant The genome into and
that genome converted that cell into
totally a new species mhm so that's a
it's procaryotic it was a cell wall you
used the ex bacterial um and micoplasma
so there's no cell wall on the same day
of our announcement uh I got comments
from President Obama and from the pope
uh in 2010 President Obama announced
that he was forming his new bioethics
commission uh to review the ethics
around making synthetic life uh the pope
said Dr venture did not create life he
just changed one of life's
Motors um
so there there are
groups with the notion
of trying to make it from a self-free
system uh we're trying to do
that but uh in my book I talk about
people talk about making life from
scratch and I use the analogy of people
making a cake and when they talk about
making cake from scratch instead of
buying a cake mix they buy a bag of
flour and and they put the different
things together it's not like they went
out and planted the seeds made the flow
made every component uh to it as Carl
Sean says to make an apple pie first you
must create the universe yes yeah that's
true and and so I think making it from
cellfree
components will happen in the next few
years we hoping even even sooner with
experiments that we're doing at The
ventro Institute right now with the
synthetic chromosome and trying to boot
that up but it it's still not doing it
from scratch instead of an intact cell
we're taking the components from a cell
and trying to do it but it would at
least prove that you can form a new cell
from scratch by having components of
lipids and everything there there's been
groups for decades is trying to put
proteins in lipid bags to see if they
could get a living
cell I've told them it's impossible they
can't possibly do that because you can't
have life without DNA uh because what we
talked about earlier the proteins turn
over in seconds to minutes you can't
have a SE living self replicating cell
without the ability to remake all the
components on a continual basis so I
would say we definitely created a new
life form that has never happened before
uh by humans in history and we've shown
the principle that the genetic code is
the driving force of life and that you
change the code you change the species
we're trying to do it without a cake
mix but it still gets down to
definitions of well you know you didn't
make the ribosome yourself
you didn't make these other proteins
yourself so you didn't make the DNA the
fact that you can convert
Life by writing the genetic code from
scratch we start with four bottles of
chemicals I think makes it more of a
theoretical argument
than an actual one but proving that we
can take just the genetic code with
components and get a cell denovo I think
would be a nice addition yeah genetic
Technologies including gene therapy and
synthetic biology are surrounded by
ethical social and safety concerns
however despite being controversial they
offer promising opportunities to
revolutionize medicine improve
personalized treatment and Tackle
various challenges of human life so it's
essential to stay up to date with the
latest developments in this exciting
field for instance recently the FDA
approved the very first treatment to use
the gene editing tool known as crisper
which my wonderful guest on today's
episode Craig Venter talks about they
just approved it but the media landscape
surrounding these developments is often
fragmented making it hard to find
Reliable information and find a balanced
view which is personally why I love
ground news so much I even deleted the
iPhone news app that's default on my
phone and replaced it with ground news's
widget app and I also bought it for a
present for my older brother Kevin
ground news is an app and a website that
gathers together all the world's media
into one place where readers can compare
coverage and see the full picture of
what's being reported worldwide for
every story you get a quick visual
breakdown of the news outlets reporting
it including their political bias how
factual the source is which entity owns
the source and which countries are
actually reporting and covering the
story for example let's return to the
fda's approval for the first criser
treatment right away you can see that
162 news outlets have reported on the
story of these 162 Outlets 23 % lean
left 11% lean right and an overwhelming
66% come from the center you can even
see who owns the outlets reporting on
the story 63% are media conglomerates
ground news also makes it easy to
compare the headlines to see how the
bias might shape and influence the
framing of the story and affect our
understanding of it one of my favorite
features of ground news is the blind
spot feed which allows you to see
stories that are underreported by either
side of the political Spectrum ground
news lets you get a deeper understanding
of the complexity and new Nuance of
different issues by identifying media
narratives and their biases you can see
every side of the story and thus develop
a well-rounded worldview which is pretty
substantial in these turbulent times you
get access to newspapers and things that
are very hard to find go to ground.
newsd Brian to stay fully informed on
breaking news and compare media coverage
sign up or subscribe through my link for
30% off unlimited access if you support
the mission and find it as essential as
I do to Scientific literacy okay there's
four questions from this uh person named
c
Cruz first one how resilient are cells
and now he's bringing out Michael 11
again a different person Michael Lan
says they are quite remarkable in
adapting to harsh environments are cells
intrinsically resilient there's no
Universe universal statement about it we
we have microbial forms that live in
ph11 water we have ones that live in uh
extreme acid pH pH one or less if you
put your finger in the water the skin
would dissolve so these organisms live
in that we have organisms I said earlier
that live up to
135° Centigrade you know we we would die
very rapidly at those
temperatures proteins uh sort of fall
apart at 100° Centigrade but in boiling
water and so we're beginning to think
it's the boiling AC
that mechanical Action Mechanical action
not just temperature alone that causes
them to fall apart and when we sequenced
the first ARA it was a methanogen with
Carl wo all these this is methanogen
grows about 85 de cenr lives by
converting CO2 into
methane um we have the extreme
radioactive radiation resistant
organisms dinus radiodurans that can
take huge doses of
radiation basically radiation does break
the chromosome apart uh but it seems to
have extraordinary DNA repair mechanisms
for putting it back together so the
answer is yes we can find life in the
most extreme environments that you can
imagine that don't work for a human
Centric view of life so this one's kind
of a yes or no question could we
terraform Mars and if so what life form
should would do that and I would add a
question you know could we Terra Reet
terraform Earth in the sense could we
develop a life form that could scavenge
you know as well as a tree does the CO2
in the atmosphere in Reverse you know
carbon carbon capture anyway could we
how would you if you had infinite if you
had Francis Collin's budget and Anthony
fouche's budget how would you use that
money Francis col doesn't have a budget
anymore unless his wife gives him one
but uh um uh so uh uh yeah how would you
terraform Mars and Earth well keep in
mind that Earth didn't start out with an
oxygen atmosphere our
oxygen atmosphere came from life so
whether it came from uh panspermia life
or just
spontaneous uh versions here eventually
the cells that convert uh light into
oxygen and CO2 or why we're alive today
and big portion of the organisms that
we've discovered in the ocean uh in fact
we found all kinds of other ones that
deal with light and energy if we wipe
those out we wipe out our ability to
live here Mars doesn't have an ocean and
Comm it supposedly has subsurface oceans
that you know still has to be toally
proven but I think the data looks pretty
good on that and uh if there's oceans
that have seawater in them and they have
oxygen or even no oxygen we will find
life forms there do you think it's
possible to terraform Mars I mean with
with Biology alone or you know so as we
discussed a little bit earlier with
people going up there and things were're
sending up there we're already
contaminating
it whether we terraform it into you know
an earthlike planet or you know a
cesspool remains to be seen so it
depends what you mean by terraform I
guess make earth 2.0 like elon's you
know if you know one of the things
uh that the planetary scientists are
discovering they're discovering all
these earthlike planets some are just
straight oceans 100% ocean water worlds
water worlds and uh they certainly have
life uh if
not uh we could uh send uh you know a
few inoculations up there and and get
some photosynthetic organisms uh going
there so yes under the right
circumstances I think it's totally
possible to do that I want to run an
argument by you I've used it on folks
from Joe Rogan to other uh individuals
and that's the following if I tell you
my colleague upstairs or down the hall
from here in the astronomy department
UCSD I tell you that she's discovered a
double planetary system at least two
planets they're both Rocky we can tell
from their Mass their density their
orbital periods and their distance from
their host star which is a type 2 G2 uh
subdwarf just like our son they're in
the habitable zone of that host star if
I tell you there's two planets there and
one of them we see um you know there's
like blinking lights and there's like
looks like you know uh you know
superconducting levitating monals and
and then um and then I just asked you
just knowing that there's one of these
two planets has is teaming with life
technology all different speciation and
so forth and I said Craig can you tell
me what would you guess the probability
is that the neighboring Planet which we
haven't we just haven't had time to
point the web telescope to but she'll
get to it um what would you guess the
probability that that planet would have
life also in the habitable zone of that
same host star system
so let me rephrase it a little bit I'm
certain that we will find microbia real
life ubiquitously throughout the
Universe the arguments that I've heard
that make sense to me that
expecting Evolution to create higher
life forms assuming that's what we
humans are you know there's a lot of
random things that happen that probably
helped higher life evolve here such as
the mass extinctions right and the
various events that took place so it's
you know there's not a simple recipe
that this was a linear track that we
went to from a viral microbial world uh
to higher life forms right but just like
my idea that life happens uh
multicellular life clearly does happen
uh if you look at the sheer diversity uh
of what we have and these things that
are found in the deepest high
temperature vents now some of these
animals are just incredible looking like
they you know better than anybody's
imagination for what space creatures
would look like so it's really a
question of rates of evolution and
conditions for that if it hasn't
happened it it will happen and it's just
uh it's more in your room has there been
enough time you know is the universe too
young to have that happened multiple
times guess my my argument that I keep
trying to make and you know people push
back on me is I say it must be we must
be able to in a basy in you know prior
updating your prior sense it must be
possible to say something about the fund
or facundity of life in the universe and
its resiliency based on the Earth Mars
system and that we know there are these
two so the system I was talking about is
obviously the Earth Mars system and the
fact that we haven't found now we
haven't explored every square millimeter
of Mars but of course and you brought
this to my attention just now you know
the underwater you know potential
evidence for underwater ocean the
extremophile you know city of
extremophiles on Earth deep smokers all
the stuff that you you've mentioned
today acidic life radiation life carbon
dioxide filic life you know um anerobic
bacteria and so the fact that we haven't
seen it's impossible to say that we
there's absolutely no way we can use the
non-observation of life in our solar
system outside of Earth and I think it's
controversial I don't understand why why
it is I mean I have colleagues like Lee
Cronin who's been a guest on the podcast
remotely I've never met him but you know
thinks there's life everywhere and they
kind of use this Carl Sean argument from
contact with andrean who I had on the
podcast she's amazing person and that's
you know well if there is no life it's
an awful waste of space and I say well I
went to Antarctica twice and I saw
almost no life besides the red you know
patch wearing uh penguin-like creatures
including scientists that was it you
know but if our visual acurity was
different yes and you could see what I
saw right with DNA sequencing I guess I
mean technologically
the the planet would you know if we
could see microbes I mean
because I've gone diving and swimming in
some of the most pristine crystal clear
water that has 10 million viruses per
milliliter in it right we it's beyond
our visual Acuity and and so we don't
have the
senses to detect life on our own Planet
we've had to develop specialized tools
to do that and those have only happened
in my lifetime I don't think we've done
the right experiments yet to look for
Life on Mars they're trying to they're
going to be having a drill that drills
down a little bit it probably won't get
down to the subsurface oceans yet you
know that it just need bigger equipment
and things to do that we haven't sent a
sequencer up there yet to to try and
look at things guess yeah no you're 100%
right I guess my my thought is but there
are high energy bonds there are you know
chemical signatures of Life uh found
almost every place that's looked oh yeah
no I stipulate there's life in the
universe I do think it came from the
earth as as we I think we're in violent
agreement about that or it or it came
from Mars and Earth was terraformed then
the terraform right um but the question
is are there Advanced technological life
I think that's the interesting question
and some have proposed many different
way ways that that could happen and not
see of them and there could be so many
different variables but I guess you know
again it has to be the current you know
understanding has to be that we don't
know of any and I think we we have to be
guided by it we have to be open-minded
and people in my channel be screaming
you know like why are you so
close-minded to uaps being actual
extraterrestrial intelligence and and I
say look no one would be more excited
for there to be actual aliens and a
physicist right probably you know
molecular biologist kind of kind of a
phys I'd love to do their genome first
yeah you right I'd love to know the
physics of the 28th Century you know uh
but you know today when you look at what
are the actual you know kind of proof
Texs given you know is it is there some
barrier I I always joke you'll make fun
of me I'm sure but you know we couldn't
be having this conversation now I mean
there it might have happened at some
point in human evolution or in the
evolution of Technology on this planet
whether by humans or some other creature
but we are using these lights and these
are kind of rendered impossible but for
the fact that we had a lot of whales
that lived on the planet and we had a
lot of you know these these primordial
bacteria that made so if we didn't have
that we wouldn't be you know it's not
like you can make a solar panel from a
solar panel like the first computer
wasn't made on a computer it wasn't
designed so to what extent are these
things you know dependent on or
contingent upon you know the the exact
circumstances that we had with you know
pre early explosion of life and then and
then the petrochemicals that enabled the
industrial Evolution which then enabled
the information reolution
so the thing that think about a couple
things just probabilities and the rate
of genetic mutation mhm so one of the
biggest findings that we talked about in
the book was that in the ocean where
it's exposed to UV light and oxygen
instead of single punctate organisms
that were used to of
classification we found these huge
clouds of tens of thousands of closely
related ated species all doing
photosynthesis all generating oxygen but
differing as much as 50% in their
genetic code wow now we're plus or minus
5% from all other mammals right right
like aans were 1% so if you you think of
that diversity Gene order and function
is
maintained and one of the biggest
discoveries we made was that the viruses
so the phase that sort of regulate the
microbial density uh in the oceans they
don't want to kill their host in fact
the most profound Discovery was that the
phase take in new copies of
photosynthetic genes to upgrade the
software of their host to keep them
really
robust so it makes you think philosophic
well then are viruses in charge but
viruses are not living
entities and can only reproduce in their
host but they keep their host alive to
do this but the mutation rate is really
high so our synthetic minimal cell uh a
group took it and took it through uh 300
cell divisions and measured in that time
so that's that's equivalent I think they
said
20,000 uh human
lifespans and the cell underwent a very
high rate of
mutation and became a much more robust
organism just in this short period of
time from the minimal cell that we had
created it became a much more robust
life form so when you understand these
rates of mutation particularly caused by
UV light by radiation by chemicals I
think it's virtually imposs possible not
to
find higher life at least multicellular
life and once you start multicellular
life you're on the route uh to higher
life forms because multicellular life
needs to have coordinated control
centers that's how nervous systems
develop it's like the
oceans what people thought of them 10
years ago versus what our studies showed
somebody asked me what ended up being a
kind of profound question question so
you proved all these things that we
didn't know exist exist what else don't
we know yeah and and so the unknown
unknown you know so we don't know what
we don't know but it has to be a lot
just like we couldn't detect these
before DNA
sequencing we don't necessarily have the
means to
detect uh something a thousand light
years away whether there there's you
know
intelligent life there or not um is
there a problem with information
overload that you're going to just have
like you said we only know 1% of what
the human genome and that's been
sequenced for 20 years than to you so
collecting more and more is it just kind
of like I can't even think of the
analogy just like one of my kids just
collects Pokemon cards and he'll never
be able to do anything with them because
he's going to run out of Interest before
he runs out of available Pokemons right
so is this information overload well I
it it can be
until there's new tools developed right
I mean and so in your field you're
looking for new methods to pick up new
signals yeah I think the most profound
Discovery in history would be to not
find life everywhere else I think that
would be the more disturbing finding
than to find it ubiquit throughout the
Universe and just
statistically now that we know how many
earthlike planets there are in the
goldilock zone
um I'm certain there has to be higher
life than just microbial life what would
count uh so I I've asked this in the
context of my cosmology friends who are
now along with my myself and my team uh
mates on the Simon Observatory were
poised there are 17 fundamental
Elementary particles neutrinos quarks
electron Photon higs boson Etc three of
them we don't know their energy uh or
their mass energy levels we know that
there's a bound we have a lower limit
and we have an upper limit but we
haven't detected their Mass they're the
neutrinos we know they have Mass from
nutrino oscillation experiments we know
from cosmology that and from laboratory
experiments that they have an upper
limit that they can't be bigger than or
else they would have been detected and
measured um so I asked M uh high energy
collider physics friends you know the
guys the lawrences the you know the
fermes ET I say to them what degree of
belief will you have when we on the
Simon Observatory hopefully in four
years time or less we tell you the mass
of the neutrino is exactly
0275 uh M you know electron volts 27
electron volts which is consistent with
upper and lower limits will you believe
it because now we're on your Turf now we
are infringing upon the the land last
trotten or first trotten by the
lawrences and the fermes and the
oppenheimer's you know laboratory
Collision physics we now we're using the
cosmos as our particle col will you
trust us and I get about 50/50 half of
them say yeah well it half of them
saying no unless I can reproduce it in a
lab experiment I won't believe you I
want to ask you my astronomer friends
you know see a signature of you know
methane or you know uh some kind of
weird uh you know carbon dioxide or
something like that on another planet
carbon bonds carbon Bond yeah they they
see a Benzene ring or whatever uh or or
you know they and it's not like all
ditch or you know will you believe it
will you believe that what will it take
for the whole biology Community to
accept that an astronomer has made a
discovery of their domains expertise I.E
life DNA what would it be but that's
happened over and over again in my view
that that these chemicals are found and
you know my view every place we have the
same chemical components we're going to
have life but we won't be able to do a
lot I mean we made chemical experiments
we can do we can go to to the Salt Flats
of of Chile and then we can go to Old
Faithful and we can say oh yeah they are
extreme but we can't do we can't say
well here's this chemical it might not
be DNA it might be something else right
it's most likely going to be DNA because
we find the nucleic acid building blocks
out there we find the protein building
blocks out there we need tools that
maybe could detect Polymers of those
things uh versus but the bond does show
you that there's connections I I mean I
I I assume those things are widely
accepted I didn't know anybody doubted
it but I guess in this day of people not
believing science at all uh I'll just
say like if you couldn't rep if you
couldn't throw it into do shotgun
sequencing or you you'd never be able to
touch it it's it's 80 light years away
you know well you know science is a very
bizarre field particularly compared to
the political domain
today and there's a lot that's flawed in
science you know we're up to 25% of
papers are are fraudulent to some extent
and with chat GTP I'm sure that that's
going to get worse wor
there's 20 times more scientists alive
today than when I got my PhD at UCSD in
1975 which means it's 20 times harder to
get a Nobel Prize presumably or other
things but uh infinitely in my case yeah
but the the ethics of
science at least what I was taught here
by the best biochemists in the world was
an essential part of science
um and that's slipped away and it's
totally slipped away to nothing in
politics and in the fake news and you
know people will believe their soap
opera but they won't believe what comes
out of
science there's a lot that's wrong in
science and I was citing things earlier
like junk DNA and other Notions like
that the difference between science and
politics is science is self-correcting
yes
you you can have these crazy
ideas that you wonder how they ever
develop and science is not infallible
because it's done by people that uh you
know want their story want you it's part
of their Fame uh to become
Dogma but it self corrected and you know
the voy of sorcer corrected more Dogma
in one set of experiments than a a lot
of things have and and to me that's
that's the real pure beauty about
science it is
self-correcting um it's loaded with
false ideas and false
Notions and limited thinking because we
didn't have the data that's why people
thought there were 300,000 human genes
soon as we had the data that changed
overnight all these things will
eventually be self-correcting how much
of society believes them is a different
thing than at least the upper end of the
scientific Community the people that
doing science and putting ethics first
you know which I hope is still the
majority of scientists but it's uh you
know we're being challenged all the time
with these Notions so uh the
self-correcting nature of it means that
you know all the future discoveries are
are going to be mindbending yeah so one
last question from the audience this is
from a friend Greg he was asking about
your thoughts on this new discovery or
this new Gene editing treatment that
cuts dangerous cholesterol it was a very
small study but I guess that's scientist
this is at Verve Therapeutics in Boston
they announced that a treatment appeared
to reduce cholesterol levels markedly in
patients it appears to be safe but
there's only 10 patients I guess it's
better than no you know six rats or
something you know but what are your
thoughts about this would you ever
undergo you know Gene editing for your
for uh yourself so there's two kinds of
Gene editing Gene editing that's on xvos
so you take cells out of the body you
change genes so this is being done for
new approaches to cancer chemotherapy a
lot of diseases It's very
effective it's in my mind totally
ethical and reasonable to do the other
time of Gene editing is germline editing
where you change your genetic code for
all future descendants of you in the
sperm or egg or yes and that's what
we're not ready for we don't have enough
knowledge to know how to do
that uh people are still with limited
thinking that there's one gene one
function in fact there's plat tropism is
the the rule not the
exception um we did editing of the pig
genome and uh uh to get Pig organs for
human
transplantation can you get them to chew
their cud because I'd really like to
start eating them you know
I'm kosher so I can't but uh if you
could edit their genes and make them
chew they're good well so we put human
genes in the pigs so I I don't know if
you eat bacon from those is that
cannibalism now but uh um but we've
changed it so that the organs aren't
immediately rejected there's you know
we've only changed 10 genes so far but
the two heart transplants that have been
done with our ten Gene uh pig heart
lasted longer than the first human to
human transplants but they still didn't
last uh for a super long time you know
there's a million people that need
kidneys a year in the US and can't get
them and so we're trying this approach
but the reason I'm starting this so I
sequenced the strain of pigs that we
were
using and we looked for a place what we
call a landing pad uh a place in the
genome that not subject to ring
combination and genetic
variation so we could insert new genes
there and not have them uh be part of
you know rapid Evolution and changes we
don't know enough yet about how the
human genome functions you know we're
lucky these studies with the pig worked
out and I think it's because we did that
preliminary work crisper is a wonderful
Discovery and a wonderful
tool but a lot of people don't
understand the fundamentals of it
crisper has what's called of Target
effects so it's used on you know you use
DNA primers these are just short pieces
of DNA sequence you pick them that
recognize the site that you want to
change but in six billion base pairs in
the human genome there's multiple sites
so they're called of Target effects so
people look at the gene they're
interested in they see they're making
the changes they want but when we use
crisper editing the pig we
resequence the whole genome uh to look
for off Target effects that could be
knocking out another Gene so we're not
ready to
use crisper alone to do germline gene
therapy so all these things sound great
people have talked for decades you know
when I first started in the human gen
and that's ever all I ever got on TV
interviews are we going to edit the
human genome and genome meth thesis like
to talk about you know the ethics of
doing enhancement uh versus getting rid
of diseases so it's a it's a space we're
very early on and not ready for germ
line changes got it well we've reached
the point where my bladder will not
allow us to continue beyond these final
three questions and they're all in some
way related to Sir Arthur C Clark and
you had that conversation with um our
director Eric ver recently and so you
know that uh Arthur C Clark was very
quotable and in fact we'll get to the
origin and the name of this podcast at
the very end of these three questions
well final one of the three uh but the
first one hearkens to his famous
statement that any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from
Magic and uh that's a quote we open
every podcast with because we have him
recorded in his own voice and I want to
ask you of all the invent itions and all
the discoveries that human beings have
made either yours or others which one do
you find the most magical and the most
be you know bemusing and and delightful
of all human technology we were totally
stunned when we transplanted the
chromosome and it boed up and created a
new species that that you know pretty
cool that's what we were hoping for but
but but it was pretty cool to actually
see it happen you know I depend on
breakthroughs in physics and chemistry
with trying to
critize the phenotype of
individuals you know I'm Blown Away by
how effective MRI works by looking
vibration of water
molecules uh and how that can diagnose
cancers with some of the postprocessing
algorithms were developed here at UCSD
so you know when it's not part of the
repertoire we can do with our hands or
we can see with our visual Acuity that's
right it it of course all seems like
magic
because if you're not using those tools
you you can't see it that's right that's
what my favorite quote from Galileo he
said you should measure what's
measurable and make measurable what's
not yet so I think that's uh exactly in
line with what you said okay well that's
Galo I didn't that's Galo yeah that's
Galileo Einstein I've got Carl Sean I
only have one of a person who's actually
on the podcast and that's n Chomsky
somewhere over there I can't find I
should have brought my bobble head that
I was visit I'll expect that for you
around too or I'll come visit you in jcv
okay next question is another quote from
Sir Arthur and he said the following he
said when an elderly but distinguished
scientist says something is possible he
is very likely to be correct but when he
says something is impossible he is most
likely wrong and I want to ask you not
calling you elderly or what have you but
uh but I want to ask you what have you
been wrong wrong about what have you
changed your mind about what do you
regret if anything well I'm on my third
marriage the second marriage is a
Triumph of wi of of Hope over exper
what's the third Mar so I I I learned
from my mistakes and
iterated scientific method Soul learner
and uh I I finally got it right uh but
it took a while yeah I think what I've
been most wrong about sadly
is gauging people and their motivations
the most delightful experience I had was
at Solera where people just came in
wanted to be part of it they believed in
what I was doing they wanted to be part
of History they wanted to contribute
their knowledge to that in the purest
fashion and and everybody exceeded even
their own expectations of themselves
with doing things that that was the best
of scientific Humanity that that I've
ever personally experienced when I
started human
longevity I naively kind of expected the
same thing but when I started Sara the
world hadn't heard of me uh other
scientists had but you know was pretty
much an
unknown and now I was a known name one
of the 10 most known names currently in
science
and despite what people said their
motivations were clearly very different
uh to come and join the project to try
and mix phenotype with genotype and and
create human longevity and uh I I take
people at face value which I learned is
not always the wisest thing to do but
uh in my mistake is
reading my
motivations and ideas into to other
people and
uh and I've been helped you you you've
read my books so you know you know I was
thrown in the brig twice you know I've
had some wonderful Second Chances and
second opportunities and I constantly
believe in giving people second tries
and Second Chances it works out probably
1 to 2% of the the time and that's a
disappointed you know cuz it was so
profound in my own life um so I'd say my
biggest failing has been it's been my
biggest success and my biggest failing
in is
selection of people to work
with so the last question actually maybe
touches upon what you were just saying
but maybe we can elaborate a bit more
and that's the final of Sir Arthur's
famous quotes which is actually the
origin of the name of this podcast and
he said the only way to know the limits
of the possible is to transcend them and
go into the impossible that's my podcast
name I want to ask you in the form of
advice to your younger self you speak
candidly about your time in Vietnam and
how you actually attempted suicide by
swimming out to sea and obviously it
didn't work thank God because the world
would have been devastated right I want
to ask you if you had 30 seconds with
your 20-year-old self what would you say
what would you give him to give him the
courage rather to go into the impossible
so I actually
learned the lessons that are key to my
success probably in Vietnam I learned
some of them
earlier uh being a competitive swimmer
yeah I was a lousy student and I know
now why it's because I have a Fantasia
instead of a photographic memory and the
school system selects for photographic
memories and so I nearly flunked out of
school and uh uh part of beleving in
myself is when I started from nothing
and became a champion swimmer and that
you know sports do give people a lot of
self-confidence uh because you learn
physically what you're capable of and I
would beat people that were technically
much better swimmers than me uh just
because I was more motivated to win my
mentor here at UCSD Nate Kaplan said the
biggest failing that most scientists
make is they talk themselves out of
doing the experiment
uh and that's true you see it over and
over again everywhere you look and some
people are afraid to succeed some people
are afraid to fail that it covers all
all the range of
things in
Vietnam I learned all I had to lose was
my
life and uh came close to doing that a
number of occasions uh one as as you say
was potentially self-induced but uh a
shark told me to wise up I came back
probably more Fearless you know than was
good for me reporter from nature uh who
read the book and was writing a review
on it she goes uh you had a lot of
near-death experiences on this in this
voyage and I said well they they weren't
planned to be that I've learned to
believe in my unique type of thinking
the combination of conceptual thinking
with
tuition I've learned to trust it more
importantly I believe in myself and my
ideas you know and it's a narrow range
because you slip a little bit one way
they can become delusions of grandeur
and you you go off the crazy Spectrum I
think I'm
successful
from having tremendous capabilities of
doing things myself you know one of my
biggest problems in science was giving
up doing the
experiments cuz I could do them so much
better than anybody else and taking over
on things but it's believing in yourself
and you know failure is nothing compared
to losing your life you know for a
worthless cause yeah and seeing it um
through those lenses and it's quite
emotional to hear you speak with such
cander about it and yeah to me it's I'm
thankful that you that you saw the light
or that shark intervened and however
however it happened
serendipitously uh we'll never know but
they say uh uh I believe it was uh
schopenhauer oh no it was kirar kard
said life can only be understood in
Reverse but unfortunately it must be
lived going forward I want to thank you
uh Craig for your so much of your time
and your influence on me and millions of
people and uh you call you the Merlin of
the of the of the biological realm so
thank you so much for sharing your time
thank you for having me